welcome back to the David Pakman show. I am
Farron cousins sitting in for David Pakman
today. Let's talk about policy for a little
bit here. You know we've got two major policies
that could horribly the fact that United States
happening right now, one of which is actually
already horribly affecting the United States
and that happens to be Donald Trump's trade
war. Now, this past weekend, Fox News ran
an op ed on their website by Andy positive
and in this op-ed, Mr Pazdur decides to go
after the Democrats running for president
for being completely backwards on trade, allegedly.
Here's a few quotes out of this. This is absolutely
craziness here. What Mr Positive, he writes,
he says, Trump's opponents accuse him of starting
a dangerous trade war with China, China, but
in reality, China has been waging economic
war against the US. For decades, president
Trump just decided it was time for America
to start fighting back.
By fighting back, does he mean file for bankruptcy
and alarming rate because that's what's happening
to our farming farming communities. Thanks
to Donald Trump's trade wars. Does he mean
that people are contemplating suicide in this
country because of the effect these trade
wars are having on their businesses, their
livelihoods, their life? Because that's also
happening. Those reports started coming out
last week. People's lives are being destroyed
because of these trade wars and these republicans
cheerleaders like the ones on Fox News who
say, heck yes, stick into China. They don't
understand what's actually happening because
none of it affects them. There isn't a single
person working on the air on Fox News who
is affected by this trade war, by any of the
tariffs whatsoever. They're not having to
pay a price.
Consumers are average. American citizens are
small business owners are large business owners
are but not fox. And that's why they're able
to sit out there, talk about things they don't
understand, and I'm going to get to that in
just a second, but act as cheerleaders for
the president's horrendous policies. And here's
what I mean when I say they don't understand.
Most people don't understand trade deficits.
They don't understand the economics of trade.
It is, believe it or not, an incredibly complex
system that most economists will tell you
doesn't matter at all. And that may come as
a shock to hear, but I spent the last 48 hours
researching this, looking to see if I could
find credible economists who were willing
to come out and say that yes, trade deficits
matter. They hurt our country and we have
to do something about it. And I couldn't do
it, couldn't find it.
You know why? Because it doesn't exist. You're
not going to find a credible economist who
tells you that. Yeah, we've got to do something
about our trade imbalance with China. And
yet here we have an administration that's
been telling us for well over a year, the
child has been playing us off for suckers
that they have been taking advantage of us
is what president Trump has specifically said.
China's been taking advantage of us and he's
fighting back. Well let me ask you the audience
this question and I asked my own audience
this question last week and could not get
a single response. So please, if you do have
a response to this, feel free. Reach out to
me on Twitter at fair and balanced DME tweeted
at me and tell me when you have personally
felt victimized by the trade imbalance between
the U S in China. Trump told us we were being
victimized, they were taking advantage of
us and that it was impacting us. So tell me
a personal experience you have had buying
a good or service when you've walked away
being, Gosh Darn it, I was done. The victim
here, China screwed me again.
Again, my Twitter feed is wide open. Please.
If that has happened to you, let me know at
fair and balanced. I want to hear honest to
God. I want to hear if that has happened to
you, but you know what, I'm willing to bet
it hasn't and economists would agree with
me because here's the thing. Yes. When you
only look at bilateral trade and you see a
$300 billion trade imbalance because we're
taking more from China, then they're taking
from mosque on paper that looks bad, but also
on paper it really doesn't matter. It doesn't
technically effect the U s economy in any
significant way there. There might be small
things here and there that do get affected.
Yes, economist admit that. But beyond that,
is there a large scale ramifications for it?
No.
Yeah,
it doesn't exist. And plus, once you start
to look at the bigger picture, because this
isn't just the US and China doing business
together and everybody else just stays within
their borders. This is a global economy. So
we may have a trade imbalance with China and
we may have a trade surplus with another country
who has a trade surplus with China. But China
has a surplus with us,
but it all eventually evens out. And yes,
overall the trade deficit, we may still be
down, but if our economy is doing well, then
it doesn't matter when our economy is doing
poorly, you could make the argument that we
should reduce the trade deficit. But ultimately
economists also agree that that's really not
going to do anything to help our economy.
We are not being victimized, we are not being
taken advantage of with soybeans and steal
the one area that they say that China has,
you know, kind of screwed the u s over on
his patent infringement and copyright law,
you know, taking our ideas. Most of that has
to do with military stuff, fighter jets, things
like that. Other countries have also come
in and said China is actually hacked them
to steal their trade secrets so that they
can build tanks and planes and bombs and whatnot.
So yes, we do have an issue with that. But,
uh, putting tariffs on steel coming into the
US from China, that's not going to do that.
It's not gonna fix it. It's not even going
to address the problem. The president himself
has yet to address the real problem, but instead
wants to pass on the billions of dollars each
month in tariffs to American citizens. Now,
at this point, I don't know if the president
is just playing stupid or if he is honestly
just ignorant about how these tariffs work,
but American citizens are paying those American
businesses are paying those.
We're the ones who are suffering. We're the
ones who are having our businesses closed
their doors big and small by the are farmers
who Trump just announced he was going to give
another 12 to $15 billion bail out there struggling
and the first bail out he announced most of
it didn't even go to them. They didn't know
what to do. They didn't know how to handle
it. So the money just kind of sat there. Sure.
They bought a bunch of, uh, crops that they
couldn't sell that the farmers couldn't sell.
But that's about it. We need to work together
with the World Trade Organization to prevent
China from being a bad actor. That's the truth.
Okay, but you're not going to get there with
a trade war. It's simply isn't going to happen.
There are no winners in the trade wars, just
billions of losers.
And right now there's a few hundred million
losers in the United States who are the ones
suffering the real effects from Donald Trump's
trade wars. Because as you'll notice, he hasn't
put tariffs on any of the goods that he and
his family produce over there. He's remained
unscathed. It's just everything else that
American citizens like the buy or use that
he's screwing us over on. But don't worry,
you want to buy a Trump good. It's going to
be just as cheap now as it ever was.